[Music]
it's very exciting it's kind of what
the premiers used to be and
maybe what they'll
be again someday it's kind of fun for
audiences and people outside and
just everybody in general
that was actor gene hackman at the 1972
premiere of the godfather which opened
in theaters 50 years ago this month the
adventure everyone from rockell welch to
henry kissinger
if you've seen francis ford coppola's
epic recently on tv you know it holds up
as well as ever it's also been
re-released in theaters restored to its
original glory to get a new backstory of
the film we spoke with the author of a
book that takes his title from one of
the movie's most famous lines
leave the gun
take the cannoli
you don't offer friendship
you don't even think to call me
godfather
instead you come into my house in the
day my daughters to be married and you
ask me for the murder
money
for me it's the greatest movie of all
time
i was a 19 year old college freshman
when i saw the film for the first time
in memphis tennessee and i walked into
the theater a kid and i walked out an
adult
mark seal spent more than a decade
researching and writing a story about
the film that changed his life
a film that began as a book written by
mario puzo
the godfather was based more than
anything else on puzzles mother who
raised her kids in new york city's
hell's kitchen
by the time maria puzzo's fifth child
hit middle age
mario was a down on his luck gambling
addict having tried and failed to make
it as a writer countless times
until he finally struck gold another
asked me to come up in this i went up
there i just told him a few mafia
stories that i knew
and
they gave me in advance and told me to
go ahead the back story of how puzzle
came to write the godfather and how
francis ford coppola turned it into a
film classic
are detailed in seals leave the gun take
the cannoli
the epic story of the making of the
godfather francis coppola took that
novel and transported it to the screen
and so so much of what mario puzo wrote
is now the godfather but koppel also
dramatized it so much what the hell is
this it means look abroad she sleeps
with the fishes famously the studio
making it paramount didn't want coppola
as director they didn't want marlon
brando as the dong
they didn't want al pacino as michael
what was it about pacino's performance
for you
well because it starts off gradually you
don't know who he is
pacino said he saw the power of the role
was in the transition of it so you see
michael developed from a you know
college boy military man and then just
explodes with the that killing and
louise american restaurant in the bronx
if the studio had gotten what they
wanted and a completely different cast
and a different director
would godfather have had
any of the success that it had yeah it's
hard to imagine right i want you to rest
well and the month from now this
hollywood big shot's going to give you
what you want in the end coppola got
exactly what he wanted i'm going to make
him an offer he can refuse and his
decisions represented triumphs for then
little-known stars like pacino diane
keaton and talia shire who rounded out
the cast along with more established
actors like robert duvall and james khan
you're taking us very first but casting
battles weren't the only issue
as seal writes about new york city's
most prominent real gangster joe columbo
almost got the film killed
why did colombo want to shut down the
movie well because he was on a campaign
against the stereotyping of italian
americans in popular culture and he
thought the word mafia symbolized
everything that was wrong with the
stereotyping of italian-americans and of
course puzzles novel was originally
titled mafia
and so
uh you know the godfather soon became
something that they wanted to stop
because they thought it was going to be
a stereotypical movie about
gangsters
look how they mess with my boy
producers of the movie met with colombo
and agreed to take the word mafia out of
the script with or without those
forbidden words the shooting in the
godfather should take several months
once filming started shooting delays
pushed the original opening back from
christmas 1971. i haven't got time uh
make time
coppola and paramount's legendary head
robert evans argued endlessly over the
edits
in march 1972
the godfather was ready for its premiere
[Music]
nobody thought this was going to be this
juggernaut that it became the guest in
the lowe's state theater after the
credits roll after three hours there was
not a sound it was stunned silence and
robert evans thought it's a bomb you
know nobody's saying a word there's no
applause but what turned out was they
were stunned
beyond belief into silence and that
happened across america the godfather
went on to become at the time the
highest grossing film ever made it won
three oscars including best picture
[Music]
and eventually went into permanent
rotation on cable tv for decades
albert ruddy the producer said there's
only one and only one reason it was ever
a success
because it's about family that's right
we had seen these men as gangsters but
we didn't know that they were a family
men i am honored and grateful that you
have invited me to your home you know
how does the movie start it starts with
a wedding i made that first child be a
masculine child the title of your book
it's not in the for the original book
but it's in the movie right why choose
that title leave the gun
take the cannoli
well for me it says everything about the
movie because first of all richard
castellano says the line that was in the
script
leave the gun
but then he remembers what his wife told
him on the stoop that morning don't
forget the cannoli
the movie is about the gun the movie is
about the gangsters the movies about the
violence but also the movies about the
cannoli the family the food the
fellowship the fathers and sons the
american dream so to me that just says
everything about the godfather
and for the record here we did not
forget the cannoli
courtesy of our senior broadcast
producer tony depover straight from
court pastry shop
in brooklyn since 1948
there it is and you got it in front of
you too yeah you know right
such a rite of passage i have to say
i've already taken my bite but when i
saw the godfather i felt like oh
i'd arrived i understood
adulthood i understood america i you
know it was like one of those rites of
passage as a young woman into the male
dominated world and you know what it's
not about the masculine child it's about
the feminine child luca that's that's
what mark seal said he said he went into
the movie right 19 years old he was a
kid walked out there it is an adult i
wonder if kids still feel like if if
somebody saw it 50 years later like if a
17 year old kid so i don't know
can i admit a dirty little secret to you
guys you haven't seen that no way you're
not a father oh my god
but now i will
there it is
not unusual all right so